hello freak [ __ ]
we are already almost three hours into
this
so we haven't talked about hitler oh my
goodness well we kind of
have we kind of did we kind of have but
let me just
uh do you want to lay out your argument
about hitler and then i'll respond to it
and uh
um i don't know if i do want to i mean
um i think i i actually think that i
should stop
because i'm kind of at the limits of i'm
at the point where the probability that
i will say something stupid
is starting to increase and i would
rather not because just saying the
things that i'm trying to say that
aren't stupid is dangerous enough yes
this isn't the topic where you want to
make that kind of
yes yes i would say maybe is there a
more charged subject it's
funny that it's charged because as you
point out we're pretty much all in
agreement about it right i mean
i mean you find someone who's not and
they're instantly ostracized from
society
right i mean anybody who has an argument
about genghis khan i mean there's a
really fascinating take on this by dan
carlin from hardcore history
where he's talking about the amount of
time that has passed since a horrible
atrocity
and that there are people that will
argue that genghis khan who killed
10 percent of the world's population
changed things so badly that it
literally
lowered the carbon footprint of the
human race while he was alive
killed some untold number of millions of
people
and was responsible for their deaths
people look it to him
and they find all sorts of positive
things to attribute to his reign
opening up trade with china opening up
trade routes although all these
different things that
people have attributed to him and that
someday
someone may do the same thing about
adolf hitler
right now that is impossible he uh he
certainly made
um that job very difficult with all of
the documentation
and especially the films but um
but let's just say uh the argument that
i want to level i want to be
really careful to do this so that it
can't be misinterpreted by anybody
i'm gonna i'm gonna enjoy watching this
okay
if i'm cornered will you yeah
okay so my argument from all those years
ago in
in my uh my paper that i was did for bob
trevors that i mentioned at the
beginning
was that hitler was a monster
as we all know but he was a rational
monster
that the program that he deployed was
not what he said mind you what he said
was wrong in many places especially
where it gets near darwinism it's just
all tangled and broken but what he did
was rational from the point of view
of increasing the amount of resource
that was dedicated to
producing members of his population
and so my point is this is the danger
that we are in
if we allow ourselves to imagine
that genocidal impulses are
more or less gone from the world because
we've all assumed we've all agreed that
they're a bad
thing and the point is that they exist
in a in a latent program
and at a point when you have
austerity as a result of uh usually a
an opportunity that has run its course
and has resulted in the population
growing to fill that opportunity and
suddenly there's nowhere to go because
the opportunity has all been absorbed
the tendency of people is to figure out
who
what other population is weak and if
that population is across a border
then there's some excuse for war and if
the population is within the border then
it's a genocide but the point is that
is an ever-present danger for us okay i
want to clear clarify one thing i mean
because this argument was sort of
phrased as we have a disagreement about
hitler
and i would like to point out that i
don't actually disagree with anything
that you just said because i certain
if i remain relatively silent i don't
want to be seen
i don't want it to be seen that the fact
that i'm disagreeing with you means
or that there is a disagreement means
that it's a disagreement about any of
that i think
the disagreement was something like i
said that hitler was even more evil than
we thought he was
and you i think correct me if i'm wrong
you're pointing out the danger of
assuming that
you can put hitler in a he was just a
monster box and don't think about it
anymore and i would say
i agree absolutely with that i mean i've
studied hitler
a lot and there's a bunch of things that
you can't say about him
you can't say he was stupid right you
can't say he was without artistic talent
you can't say that he was a poor
organizer you can't say that he wasn't
charismatic
you can't say that he did wonders for
eco germany's economy in the first part
of his reign
and and and so it's very necessary when
you're
if you're dealing intelligently with the
true monster that you give the devil his
due
yeah uh so i think the thing that i saw
in your
video was your argument was that as he
was losing
instead of um putting the genocide
on pause and uh
winning and winning the award winning
that he he ratcheted up
the genesis yeah i don't know if it
would really be i don't think it's
necessarily fair
to say that it was him that did that
although i think he had a hand in it
it does appear to me that that's what
happened right and my
my point would simply be and again there
i couldn't possibly be less sympathetic
with the individual my point is simply
that from an evolutionary point of view
if your objective is coldly to increase
the number of genomes that are spelled
the same way
that yours are on earth that a
he did enslave those jews who were most
fit to work in service of the german war
machine
right that's what those camps and not
all of the camps were
work camps but you know auschwitz for
example was both a work camp and a death
camp
and so there was this uh tendency to
enslave
and so let me ask you a question about
this because
you know i think you have to make a
pretty tenuous biological argument to
say that there's evolutionary utility in
in increasing the number of your kinsmen
but
unless they're very close but but here's
a slight variation of that you tell me
what you think about this
is it reasonable to presume that a
decent
survival strategy is to homogenize your
environment with regards to under some
conditions to homogenize your
your environment with regards to racial
or ethnic differences to decrease the
probability that you and yours are going
to be killed
oh yeah again no defense of this yes but
you are right
to the extent that there's another
population that's distinct that that
population even if it is small
and has little power now might not be
small and have little power later and so
undoubtedly that program is there too
okay okay um
but i would say that the tendency to
believe that evolution only functions
at the level of kin when you're talking
about very close relatives i believe is
an
error that is the result of the fact
that evolutionists early on
wished to operationalize fitness
and it's very hard to operationalize
fitness across
population level differences and so
they built a definition that is about
immediate kin but there's no logical
reason
to imagine that that peter's out at the
edge
okay um so that you're okay so all i'm
arguing is that
what hitler did was go after a
population
inside his border that was more
distantly related to the people who were
his constituents and then he went
obviously after
eastern europe and sought the future of
germany in russia and it took
12 million russians to turn around the
german
war machine i mean those are military
deaths there were vastly more civilian
deaths but
but the point is he did not succeed in
doing what he set out to do
but he also didn't fail in the sense
that
he took a bunch of resources that
belonged to a population that was more
distantly related
and he got rid of those people
and by getting rid of them increased the
amount of resource that was available
to aryans this has nothing to do
genes are not interested in figuring out
which genes are superior all of the
language about german superiority is
nonsense
however genes are very interested
i mean they're obviously genes they
don't think but they act as if they are
interested
in replacing alternative spellings okay
and so part of the reason that you're
walking through this just
so that this the track of this remains
self-evident is to caution people
against
to to alert people to the fact that the
sorts of programs
that hitler both ran and elicited from
people
are lurking in our let's say in our
genome in our in our set of biological
possibilities
and we have to be very awake to that
fact on an ongoing basis
they are lurking in our genomes which
does not mean that we
as adults have this as a possibility
many people
will not go along with this other people
have it lurking to be triggered
you